Не так давно ці військові отримали важкі поранення на передовій.
Але тепер готуються підкорити найвищу вершину національного природного
парку "Сколівських Бескиди" - гору Парашка.
Із пошкодженням опорно-рухового апарату, ампутаціями рук та ніг
вони долають кілометр за кілометром, щоб піднятися на висоту 1268 метрів.
У горах не добре, коли темп рваний.
Так спокійно собі йдете своїм ходом - і ми встигнемо. І буде легше вам. У добру путь.
Спочатку дорога веде через ліс. Олександрові ці краєвиди приносять приємні спогади.
Адже раніше хлопець працював у лісовому господарстві.
Та після повномасштабного вторгнення він став
кулеметником у 95-ій бригаді і воював на передовій.
В Лимані ми вже були, там вже у нас рота базувалася.
Ми вже виїжджали на задачу в Кремінну, це Луганська область.
І вже там були в боях. Після чого нас перевели в Харківську область.
Там ми також побули тиждень і ось так вийшло, що я вже тут.
У липні на Харківщині під час артобстрілу військовий втратив руку.
І вже кілька місяців проходить реабілітацію.
Піднятися у гори його покликали побратими. Одразу погодився,
хоч і розумів, що після поранення такі фізичні навантаження дадуться нелегко.
Так. Нормально. Тільки коли стає спекотно, то там фантомні болі більше відчуваються.
Тобто ви відчуваєте ще болі?
Фантомні постійно. Нам дають препарати, ми їх приймаємо.
Але все одно вони постійно є. Це не те, що їх повністю прибирають.
Менше їх відчуваєш. Але, як в моєму випадку, коли спека, навіть буває елементарно,
коли гарячу їжу їси, то теж відчуваєш.
А так спокійно собі йдеш, тихо. Кожен своїм чимось займається.
Та, незважаючи на фантомні болі, хлопець впевнений: така терапія
для поранених військових дуже потрібна.
Вона допомагає відволіктися від спогадів про війну.
Це в залежності, звісно, від стану самого військового. Але якщо в загальному,
то так, якщо частіше - було б непогано. Чисто морально людей розвантажити.
Так, вони фізично втомляться. Це не тільки поранені, це в загальному і цілі люди.
Вони фізично втомляться, але потім морально відпочинуть.
Подивляться на природу, на струмки. Може, там якусь пташку побачать.
Тринадцять кілометрів в обидва боки - шлях нелегкий.
Та піднятися в гори під силу абсолютно всім. Для тих, хто не може йти самостійно,
є спеціальний пристрій "джульєтка". Це крісло-візок, завдяки якому люди
з інвалідністю долають гірські вершини. А допомагають у цьому волонтери.
Обмежень по конструкції немає. Будь-яка гора доступна. І будь-який маршрут, який є,
в принципі, доступний і для цієї конструкції, для цієї "джульєтки".
Головне - бажання, головне - мотивовані люди, які це зможуть зробити.
Проблем немає. Потрібна, в принципі, мінімальна кількість людей, яка зможе це зробити,
в залежності від маршруту. В середньому треба десь 12 людей, щоб мінятися
і підстраховувати один одного. Тут потрібно темп зберігати, потрібно зберігати координацію.
І тоді все виходить.
Чим ближче до вершини - тим крутіший підйом. І хоч цей маршрут вважається доволі легким,
проте підійматися складно. І треба бути дуже обережним.
На кожному маршруті є складнощі. Основне - це валуни і слизька частина дороги.
І, відповідно, потрібно зважати, де ти стоїш, щоб не послизнутися,
о від однієї людини залежить рух всіх інших, особливо від навігатора спереду.
Тобто, якщо людина спереду, не дай Бог, послизнеться, то можуть послизнутися
і впасти всі. Особливо під час якихось таких крутіших підйомів.
Цього разу "джульєтку" випробував Володимир. Він втратив ногу під час штурму поблизу Кліщіївки
на бахмутському напрямку. Та навіть з ампутацією намагався долати
частину маршруту самостійно.
Одна ж нога то є, то чого не йти самому? Тож так.
А як вже там руки втомилися, вже напряжно, то вже хлопці тягнули.
Сам військовий з Миколаївщини. І в горах побував вперше в житті.
Після контузії йому важко говорити, особливо - згадувати про події на передовій.
Та коли розповідає про емоції від підйому в гори - на обличчі з’являється усмішка.
Красавчики, взагалі я радий. Так, трохи тяжко, але зате як вже тут, то ух, аж ух.
Каже, наступного разу підкорюватиме вершину вже на протезі.
Це третє сходження ветеранів в гори за останні три місяці.
Їх організували в управлінні туризму Львівської ОДА.
За цей час в горах побувало майже 50 ветеранів війни.
Для військових це своєрідна ментальна реабілітація.
Щоб вони мали певну психологічну адаптацію, могли відволіктись від буденностей
певних своїх, від військових частин. Чи, наприклад, ті, хто проходить реабілітацію,
і показати таким чином, що гори доступні для кожного, що при втраті кінцівки чи ампутації,
якщо є так, що є завжди можливість подорожувати і є альтернатива.
Коли сходять, десь кажуть важко, але коли піднімаються і бачать ці всі краєвиди,
відповідно, тішаться, і це так само певна така ціль, яку вони досягають.
От дуже багато військових є, які не з Львівщини, тому для них гори Карпати
- це щось нове, це вперше, це нові емоції, відповідно, позитивні відгуки.
Побути на одинці з думками після пережитого пекла прийшов і Олексій.
Гірським маршрутом він крокує одним із перших.
На перший погляд, йому це дається досить легко.
Та ще кілька місяців тому він не міг піднятися з ліжка після отриманих поранень.
У мене множинні ураження осколками, починаючи від голови і закінчуючи п'ятою точкою.
Пошкодження хребта, пробита легеня, розрив нирки, розрив тонкої, товстої кишок,
пошкодження кишечника, перитоніт.
Опік спини 10 відсотків, я не пам'ятаю, але опік спини серйозний.
Ну, і найпростіше - це ампутація правої кінцівки.
Разом із побратимами він воював під Бахмутом, корегував артилерію
і тримав "дорогу життя". Хоч міг виїхати працювати в Італію.
Мене кликали в Академію штучного інтелекту на програмування.
Але я прийняв для себе непросте рішення і сказав, що нехай я навіть програміст,
нехай в мене немає сильно великого бойового досвіду, саме бойового,
військовий є, але бойового не було, я використаю свої знання
і свою голову в лавах ЗСУ. І пішов в десантно-штурмові війська.
Я був корегувальником. Оце літав на таких пташках, як над нами оце.
Після важкого поранення пройшло пів року, а від останньої операції - лише місяць.
Та Олексій вперто вирішив йти в гори. Зізнається, таким чином він мотивує себе
боротися далі і ставати на ноги. А ще дає приклад іншим.
Я сам пишаюся собою. Це теж дуже важливо свою самооцінку піднімати
і доводити собі те, що ти можеш зробити ще багато чого.
І враховуючи те, що я з пробитою легенею, з пошкодженим хребтом
і різними іншими пошкодженнями, ураженнями, я продовжую рухатись вперед
на рівні з усіма здоровими, цілими хлопцями і також пораненими,
то це прямо дуже класно. І розуміти те, що життя продовжується,
ти багато чого ще можеш, твій шлях не закінчений,
і ти будеш прикладом для тих, в кого опускаються руки.
Тому що якщо навіть в тебе руки не опускаються, то що вже казати за інших?
Наступного року для поранених захисників планують організовувати не лише
сходження в гори, а й сплави на байдарках, кінні прогулянки та екскурсії
визначними місцями Львівщини.
А взяти участь в таких активностях можуть не лише ветерани, а й діючі військові.